hey leute was geht ab und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neun
wehrleute ich hoffe natürlich jedes gut
da draußen wir machen heute mal wieder
ein kleines
teures wer weiß vielleicht wird es auch
geil auf jeden fall bis höchst
interessant und ich muss erstmal sagen
schau dort gehen raus dann irgendwann
von euch weil ich habe diese video idee
per instagram bekommen da meint jemand
alex macht doch mal bei cent auktionen
mit und versucht da was zu gewinnen so
und ich dachte nur was das denn abgeholt
und bin dann auf ein paar seiten
gestoßen das ist an sich ja
schon so ein bisschen wie glück spielt
jeder der 18 ist oder halt zumindest
jeder der irgendwie geld auf seinem
account hat kann damit bieten und dann
wirklich so iphones tablets fernseher
für zehn euro kaufen wenn man denn die
berechtigung dazu ersteigert das ist
nämlich ganz wichtig wir werden das
heute auf der seite snipster punkt.de
testen und wie snipster funktioniert
erkläre ich euch gleich erstmal ach so
bevor starten ja heute wird wieder was
verlost wie immer wir sind ja alex wie
adventskalender er komme ich nehme
einfach mal den hier heute wird
rausgehauen hier hier haben wir den ddos
motto ach so ich glaube dann habe ich
sogar zweimal einer road show verlost
auf alex v im livestream aber ihr könnt
heute diesen saugroboter gewinn ein mega
geil ist geil ich bin großer fan von
denen hat auch selber einen dastehen
dieser hier hatten wert von 800 euro
also wenn ihr den hut brauchte wirklich
gar nichts mehr selber machen um
teilzunehmen einfach abonnent seien von
alex w es ist ja klar und dann müsst ihr
noch einen kommentar schreiben das
scheiß egal was hauptsache er schreibt
eine kontaktmöglichkeit dazu also wie
ich euch kontaktieren kann falls er
gewinnen sollte einfach euren instagram
namen oder eure e mail und ja die
gewinner werden dann einfach per
zufallsgenerator auf meinem instagram
ausgelost sich alex w und wir machen
jetzt weiter also leute wir befinden uns
jetzt gerade auf star.de das ist keine
werbung wenn die seite scheiße sein
sollte man beim experiment werde ich
natürlich auch sagen ihr könnt schon
sehen hier sind ganz viele optionen wir
haben ihr ipad digger cyberpunk
nintendos wild schuhe weil hier unten
dann auch ganz viele optionen die
anscheinend schon abgelaufen sind hier
wurden nur apple watch für 33 cent
verkaufen ob ich das alles so glauben
kann weiß ich noch nicht aber ich gehe
erst mal von auch hier kann man auch mal
sehen für wie viel geld das produkt
zuletzt versteigert wurde also zum
beispiel das ipad r 256 gigabyte für 28
euro 78 also für den preis konnte das
dann halt gekauft werden das ganze setzt
sich folgendermaßen zusammen und zwar
hier stets ganz gut jeder aktion startet
bei einem preis von 9 euro und hat eine
bestimmte laufzeit man kann online
mitbieten und pro gebot feinheit kosten
in höhe von 50 cent an das heißt wenn
ihr 100 euro einzahlt habe jetzt 200
frei gebote jedes gebot erhöht den preis
um nur einen cent und verlängert den
countdown um 15 sekunden dadurch bleibt
der endpreis so niedrig wenn der
countdown abgelaufen ist ist die aktion
beendet der letzten da erhält das
produkt dann zum schnäppchenpreis also
ich glaube man muss auf jeden fall jede
menge glück mitbringen und auch bei dem
passenden produkt mit bieten diese ipad
option hat sich jetzt halt schon mega
für die rentiert short mache der preis
liegt gerade bei 102 euro 25 das heißt
zehn
1225 gebote wurden bereits abgegeben
also 5000 euro hat diese firma schon
damit eingenommen so finanziert sich
halt das ganze es kann allerdings auch
genau andersrum laufen hier wurden jetzt
zum beispiel nur 33 gebote abgegeben
also etwas mehr als 15 euro und so eine
apple watch kostet halt anscheinend 599
genau so funktioniert das ganze ich
fand's mega interessant und wollte das
unbedingt mal ausprobieren weil wo hat
man sonst schon die möglichkeiten iphone
oder so für zehn euro zu kaufen ich habe
glaube ich erst mal 60 euro eingezahlt
dafür konnte ich dann als 120 oder 130
gebote absetzen und meine erste theorie
war ich werde das einfach mitten in der
nacht machen weil wer ist schon um vier
uhr morgens wach und kann damit bieten
keiner das habe ich gedacht und ich bin
extra so lange wach geblieben und schaut
mal was krank weil es dann passiert ist
hey leute ich hab ne das ist so richtig
terz ich muss sagen klar ich hatte mich
auch vor informieren können aber wir
haben jetzt zwei uhr ich bin extra so
lange wach geblieben ich war schon tot
mühe um 12 hier ihr könnt das ja sehen
und alle optionen wurden einfach um 2
uhr pausieren ich habe mich jetzt gerade
jenen gesetzt wollte schön mitbieten und
jetzt sehe ich dass hier überall pause
pause pause pause bekommt man hier ein
schönes ablauf und zwölf grünen 108 x
die haben damit doch schon so viel geld
von dieser seite ich habe jetzt gerade
noch mal eine andere seite abgecheckt
hier ist das auch so und es wird überall
so sein aktueller ist ja auch irgendwo
logisch das war halt einfach dumm von
mir diese taktik gut das war wohl nix
deswegen musste ich am nächsten tag also
heute ganz normal starten und so ist das
dann abgelaufen so leute nächster tag
neuer tag neues glück sagt man ja so
schön deswegen starten wir direkt mal
rein ich habe ja gestern nacht schon
aufgeladen ach so das habe ich glaube
ich noch gar nicht gezeigt wir haben
hier jetzt moment sagt bruhn wir haben
jetzt kontostand 131 gebote das weiß ich
nicht irgendwie so 60 euro müssen das
gewesen sein ich werde noch mehr drauf
hauen wenn es nötig wird wir schauen
einfach mal die strategie habe ich
glaube ich schon mal grob erklärt ich
möchte wirklich nur auf ein produkt
gehen und damit bieten man sieht jetzt
zum beispiel
dass dieses ding hier das ist ein ipad
schon seit seit gestern um 20 uhr läuft
das ist hart lange ich glaube nicht dass
ich das in den nächsten 2-3 stunden
gewinnen werde nintendos wii-konsole
kommandiert heute gestartet um 14 uhr
und wurde das letzte mal versteigert für
13 euro 19 ich würde einfach mal
versuchen darauf zu gehen weil ich muss
ganz ehrlich sagen ich hätte natürlich
am liebsten das ipad er absolut geiles
geräte auch noch so schön in diesem
grünen gibt es einfach gibt's das in
grün aber ich glaube das wird sehr sehr
schwierig hier haben wir auf jeden fall
auch immer nur zwei bietern genau wir
können jetzt zum beispiel einfach hier
aufbieten klicken und jetzt steht hier
komme ich bin direkt schon drauf und
wenn die zeit jetzt ablaufen sollte dann
ist es meins aber es wird sicherlich
gleich einer zwischen bieten jetzt ist
schon passiert die einzigen die hier
jetzt bieten sind quattroporte daisy und
ich deswegen immer nicht ball jetzt
einfach mal 50 gebote hier drauf
gewartet mal starten mit 30 und da wird
sich zeigen vielleicht fertig gewinnen
30 gebote gesetzt warten wir einfach mal
ab
leute ich hab gerade mal folgendes
berechnet weil ich habe heute auch noch
ein bisschen was zu tun ich muss noch
getränke weg bringen ich muss noch
pakete zur post bringen ich werde jetzt
einfach folgende strategie fahren und
zwar ich glaube einfach nicht dass
quattroporte und daisy jetzt noch so
viele gebote da drauf bin wie ich es
hier vor habt natürlich kann es sein
dass leute dazukommen aber ich werde
jetzt einfach mal hier komplett die 100
gebote darauf knallen jetzt habe ich 115
offener gebot haben ungefähr 60 euro
drauf gesetzt und da alle 45 sekunden
jetzt mein gebet kommen wird habe ich 90
minuten zeit in denen ich das ding nach
hause holen muss diese 90 minuten werden
wir jetzt einfach mal abwarten ich geb
farbe sorgen machen wenn das nicht
klappen sollte werde ich noch schauen ob
ich noch was anderes ersteigern kann
ansonsten komme einfach nur damit wir
jetzt hier mal was gewinnen oder mit wir
save as gewinnen dieses parfüm ist für l
1 eur 11 weg gegangen da war ich jetzt
einfach mal hier noch nebenbei ein paar
gebote drauf wie viel weiß ich nicht
mama 25 das müsste doch eigentlich das
müsste ich doch nach hause schaukeln
oder
aber ist das jetzt gut
also für 1 euro 15 schönes paar fangen
kann ich marie schenken ich habe gerade
mal sechs gebote darauf geballer gebot
50 cent also 3 euro plus 115 plus zu ja
ungefähr zehn euro dafür zur überweisung
machen das sind leute das war doch schon
mal nicht schlecht wobei ich sehe jetzt
hier hier ja ich hoffe mal dass ich das
hier auch nach hause wo nur 73 offene
gebote aktualisieren mal kurz ich muss
alles auf die nintendos setzen deswegen
china obwohl wir warten erstmal warten
erstmal ab vielleicht keine ahnung ob
das jetzt ein guter deal war beim
internet kostet 40 euro ich habe es
jetzt ungefähr 14 bekommen alles gut
leute ich bin wieder eingestiegen ich
habe jetzt echt lange gewartet weil wir
waren die ganze zeit fünf leute anbieten
und jetzt sind nur noch zwei wieder da
und ich habe jetzt hier direkt wieder
geboten reingehauen ich habe ja noch 37
ohne witz man musste wirklich ewig
vorsitzen und das die ganze zeit
verfolgen und man kann also viel geld
verlieren wenn man am ende das produkt
nicht bekommt diese daisy dee hat say
von über 2 300 gebote jahr eingesetzt
also das ist wirklich geisteskrank
wie viel hat der typ der da drauf
gesetzt das sind meine letzten drei
gebote ich bin hier der letzte mittel
pupsi und sonst hat der glaube ich
gewonnen dann ich kann auch nicht mehr
ausgeben ich habe jetzt schon 140 euro
da reingesteckt das reicht aber auch
irgendwann mal weil ich bin jetzt echt
mal gespannt was passiert zwei offene
gebote noch von mir kommen schon der dcm
pupsi ohne witz der hat locker selber
schon 300 euro da reingesteckt er hätte
die nintendos wird doch einfach selber
kaufen können irgendwo das war jetzt
meinen letzten e1 habe ich noch wenn das
jetzt wenn das jetzt klappen würde das
wäre so wild aber
ich glaube nicht da wird es gewinnen
glaube ich
es ist mein letztes gebot gewesen ich
habe euch das glaube ich gar nicht alles
gezeigt wie lange ich hier schon vor
sitze aber ich habe um 15.30 angefangen
jetzt haben wir 19 15 30
komm schon was wo er hat sich der jetzt
kommt der nächste bingo bingo 1997 ich
weiß nicht ob vielleicht auch von der
seite irgendwelche bots länder mitmachen
oder kann ich nicht sagen also das
verfahren habe ich schon mal gewonnen
das kommt auch save an aber es ist
glaube ich wirklich nicht zu empfehlen
damit zu machen da musst du schon viel
zu viel geld haben um deine langeweile
zu vertreiben aber vor allem an die
jüngeren lasst die finger davon nicht ob
da sind auch richtige profis unterwegs
die den ganzen tag nichts anderes machen
es ist zeitintensiv es kostet extrem
viel geld und am ende wenn du pech hast
gewinnt halt nix ich glaube da kannst du
dein geld wirklich lieber in der
spielothek bringen ich habe es versucht
leute kann man nichts machen ich hoffe
euch als dennoch gefallen lasst mich
sehr gern doch nach oben da und macht
beim adventskalender mit wir sind uns
übermorgen wieder gibt es ein neues
video das was mir einen job